oh right good afternoon we're gonna go
ahead and get started with the finding
all variants with clinvar webinar thank
you all for coming please subscribe to
our YouTube channel and tell your
friends great so the purpose of this
webinar obviously is to show you guys
how to find all variants with clinvar
now the nice thing here in either the
NCBI homepage or in clinvar you can
search for either diseases or phenotypes
gene names or HGVs entries so we're
gonna start with searching by phenotype
and so here I've searched cardiomyopathy
this is just from the NCBI homepage what
I'll see is that I'll get lots of lots
of different hits with lots of different
things for clinvar I have a ton of hits
there are obviously a ton of asserted
phenotypic variants linked to
cardiomyopathy if I go into clinvar and
dig a little further I will see that I
can facet these 7075 hits that I get
over here on the left now these are all
related to cardiomyopathy because that's
what I search for the first thing I
could search for is what the phenotypic
assertion is do they say this is
pathogenic do they say this is a risk
factor do they say this is the belly the
purposes of this demonstration we're
going to select the pathogenic words so
now we can see that our clinical
significance the asserted clinical
significance is all pathogenic
now what clinvar does is aggregate these
phenotypic assertions of particular
variants and we consider them to be more
trustworthy when multiple independent
submitters have made the same assertions
so here we're going to click on the ones
that have been made by multiple
independent groups so we'll do that and
then we might also be interested in what
the molecular consequence of those
variants are so we can see that we have
something a frameshift missense nonsense
and for the purposes of this
demonstration
we'll just select them this since once
now what we can see is that we have a
whole bunch of different genes here that
are represented by this and we can also
see that in our display we get the age
TV s notation so just to show you I
could search by the HGVs notation and I
don't need the G babe
parentheses I can use the standard H TV
s notation and if I did that this would
take me to a specific clinvar page and
this is what a specific Clinton boner
page looks like if we dig down I just
like to point out that it's also
cross-reference to DB snip as well as
the thousand genomes browser and these
two stars indicate that it's been
submitted by multiple submitters in this
case three once again as I said we can
also search by gene additionally if we
click on one of these gene symbols
saying laminae it will take us to the
gene page for that particular gene so
this is the gene page for limit a and
what I can see is a whole bunch of the
isoforms down here in the sequence
viewer if I scroll down at this same
page what I can see is that underneath
the isoforms I get a whole bunch of
clinvar variants and I also get other
information down here which is really
really cool and will be the subject of
another women anyway so I see the
clinvar variants and say I'm interested
in what are the last exons I could use
just the rage tooltip to go ahead and
zoom in on the last part of the gene
and then I could mouse over what are
those clinvar purple boxes in order to
show the variants in that particular
region of that particular exon there's
another way I can do this and that is by
going to NCBI variation viewer the
easiest way in my opinion to find NCBI
variation viewer is simply to Google and
CBI variation viewer anyway
in variation viewer we can enter a
location a gene name or phenotype and we
can find particular genes say we search
for Lemon a it will display the gene
symbol for Lemon a and if we click on
this blue arrow it will display the gene
for limit a we can configure the display
to show all the isoforms but we can also
select one of the last exons in this
gene zoom bid and then we can see in the
zoomed version the clinvar variants here
by the way if you're interested in
variation viewer here's a link to a full
length variation viewer webinar I'll
give you a couple of seconds to copy
Vento also you can get there from the
NCBI YouTube channel if we scroll down
in the same page and variation viewer we
see that we can filter these variants by
a whole bunch of different things so we
can filter only the ones that are a clip
are the ones that are in DB snip or DB
VAR that is either under or over 50
nucleotides the one Center a certain is
pathogenic or likely passive pathogenic
by clinvar submitters as well as the
variant type and the molecular
consequence as we discussed earlier so
when I go ahead and filter by these
things I can look at the pathogenic be
asserted to be pathogenic variants just
in this particular exon the nice thing
too is I can see for each of these
particular variants how many
publications in PubMed support those
particular assertions going back up to
the top I can see that we can see
pathogenic variants in this exon by
looking at the purple color of those
particular variants here in fact the
different colors correspond to different
phenotypic assertions I can also upload
my own data into variation viewer and
that's covered more specifically in that
variation viewer webinar I mentioned
finally I wanted to talk about batch
download for clinvar and really the
easiest way in my opinion to do that is
to go to the FTP site so if you go to
clinvar which can be found at this URL
or just by googling clinvar then there
is a link that says go to the FTP site
and on the FTP site it's trivial to get
VCFs a VCF of all of the clinvar
assertions or those assertions in XML
depending on what you prefer to parse I
would like to thank the people on this
list formatted as a PubMed query for
help putting together this presentation
and I'd be happy to take any questions
from the audience if there are any also
I should mention that I am here with
Melissa Landrum the group lead for the
clinvar database and she will also be
able to answer questions should there be
any that I cannot easily answer so there
is a question that's actually a very
good question is there a controlled
vocabulary for conditions if so where or
what is it if not how our conditions
name search
I believe that Melissa will be able to
answer this question more eloquently
than I so I am going to pass the
microphone to her Thank You Ben so in
clinvar submitters can provide their
condition to us in several ways if they
can use an omit number hpo ID and/or
finet ID a concept ID from you MLS and
there are several options if your
condition name is not really represented
in any of these databases you can also
provide it to us as your
term once we receive all this
information to clinvar we use the med
gen database at NCBI so medgen is really
an aggregator of condition information
from many different sources including
the ones I mentioned oh man HBO orphanet
umls and it also includes novel terms
that come in directly to clinvar which
then are available to be incorporated
into you MLS as well so when you are
searching in clinvar you can search by
any of those IDs which you can also
search on just the term that you're
interested like Ben's example of
cardiomyopathy all right are there any
other questions the slides will be
available on the NCBI FTP site but there
will be a convenient link on the NCBI
webinars page again this video should be
available on YouTube in the next week or
two and if you liked the video and
thought it was informative please tell
your friends with that unless there are
any other questions
we are going to go ahead and sign off we
hope you enjoyed this week's NCBI minute
and we should have either an NCBI minute
or a full-length webinar every week for
the rest of the summer have an excellent
day
you